now it is tough to try to rank our
favorite reactions to last night's CNN
town hall with President Trump but what
you're going to try so we're going to
have a little fun and count down our top
three kind of sports center style all
right let's start with number three
a post-town hall focus group didn't
quite go as planned for CNN
does it bother you that he keeps talking
about 2020 and not 2024. how do you feel
about those lies you guys asked him the
first question at the Town Hall about
the 2020 election rather than current
stuff so don't you think you could say
it's time for me to start talking about
2024 and not lies that aren't true
couldn't the media ask him a question
about 2024
now I'm most I'm most Kamala cackled at
that one surprise most voters are
smarter than CNN all right coming in at
number two msnbc's struggle to come to
terms the fact that another Network
actually hosted a town hall with a
former president
truly stomach turning the hurricane of
Lies is almost difficult to annotate it
was a shameful and disgraceful thing to
see but I think that he is running on an
explicitly authoritarian program I think
it was a profoundly irresponsible
decision it was shameful the thing that
gave me an actual like feeling like I'd
been punched in the stomach with the
reports of the crowd the treatment of
the moderator by Trump was in every
classical description we don't really
often apply it to politics abusive
abusive would be having to watch liberal
mom Chardonnay hour each afternoon on
MSNBC
and last but not least our number one
courtesy of the imbecilic talking
pompadour and namesake of Morning Joe
no surprises and yet it was just it was
a disgraceful uh performance I I can't
believe I'm I'm going to use
catastrophizing language here uh but it
was it was just it was disgraceful on
every level what I saw last night at
least was as chilling as anything I've
seen on television since January the 6th
thank you
that three-quarter zip almost just came
flying right off of him he was so upset
joining me now Newt Gingrich former
Speaker of the House Fox News
contributor
um author of the new book March to the
majority newt
the freak out and the long faces I mean
I've got to say my kids and I sometimes
watch some of these shows in the morning
before they go to school we were
screaming laughing this morning because
like my 12 year old's like oh how well
everyone looks so upset why are people
so upset I said because Trump did really
well at this town hall and then he just
said when's breakfast new what about
this
well look I mean Charles Dickens wrote A
Tale of Two Cities someday somebody's
going to write a tale of two countries
uh what you have on the left is a group
of fantasizers who thought that the
Russian hoax was real they thought that
the uh the intelligence Community attack
on the hunter Biden laptop was real you
go down the list every time they turn
around they know Trump is bad they wake
up in the morning chanting Trump is bad
they go to bed at night chanting Trump
is bad and they're shocked to find out
that more and more Americans don't agree
with them the average American now faced
as you point out in the last segment
faced with Biden's millions of illegal
immigrants faced with the total collapse
of crime in big cities faced with the
inflation rate that's eating up our
family budgets you go down the list and
they're going let me get this straight
Donald Trump is fighting for me and they
are fighting against Donald Trump and
what that does is it makes Trump
stronger he his current numbers in a
Republican primary are so staggering
that I doubt if he'll be in a single
debate between now and getting the
nomination because there's no reason for
him to he's these 25 30 points ahead of
anybody else and the reason is he is
seen by everybody on the right as the
one person with the courage and the
strength to stand between them and a
truly crazy left-wing establishment and
we know it's true because we've now
watched him take this beating for seven
straight years and he's still standing
it's an astonishing person yeah what
about the GOP Elite types The
Establishment types he saw some of them
trotted out today uh you hear about John
cornyn or thune or Todd young uh Bill
Barr said it would be a disaster Trump
would get nothing done in another term
what about all those characters
well I think that's what you get in a
period of really dramatic party change
when Franklin Delano Roosevelt took over
the Democratic party their previous
nominee Al Smith left the Democratic
party because it had changed too much
for him I think the these things happen
Donald Trump represents a dramatic
reorganization of American politics he's
turning the Republican Party into the
working class party the Democrats are
becoming the party of the elite wealthy
of the elite sort of the John Kerry
windsurfing party and that is a radical
transition in American politics and
frankly some of the old-time Republicans
are going to be happier windsurfing with
John Kerry than they are going to be
eating hot dogs with Donald Trump
all right Newt great to see you tonight
in rare form